The SCP Foundation’s most famous anomalies
are legendary.
From the notorious 682 in its acid bath to
Pesterbot, some SCPs are instantly recognizable
from only an image or a few sentences of information.
But the SCP Foundation also encompasses endless
universes and possibilities, and that means
endless variations on these iconic anomalies.
Maybe in one reality 173 is simply one of
many terrifying statutes, or perhaps 682 is
a heir to the infamous infernal Scarlet King.
And of course, there are other versions of
the Foundation itself too!
From worlds where they are known as the Foundation
Incorporated, and seek only to line their
own pockets, to realities where the Foundation
is a theocratic organization holding the line
after the apocalypse.
What follows is a peek into one such alternate
universe, and their version of one of the
Foundation’s most mysterious and enigmatic
anomalies.
Can you guess what it is?
Some people think the Foundation’s operations
are limited to the land, air, and sea.
To some extent, they’re right - while the
vast majority of anomalies exist on Earth,
the O5 Council knows that space is infinite
and that means infinite possibilities for
anomalies.
That’s why the Foundation has sites on the
Moon, on space stations orbiting Earth, even
installations on Venus and Mars.
There are even rumors that the Foundation
retains their very own small fleet of space
shuttles to move some of the particularly
dangerous anomalies off-planet where they
pose no risk to society.
But space goes well beyond just our neighboring
planets.
The Foundation also invests heavily into exploring
deep space, so that they might find anomalies
like the Hateful Star before they pose a danger
rather than after.
To this end, they’ve sent a small army of
space probes, equipped with advanced sensors
and rudimentary artificial intelligence, in
every direction away from our planet to scout
for potential anomalies.
But the issue is that sometimes the probes
actually end up encountering anomalies.
Such is the curious case of Probe H9, which
disappeared under mysterious circumstances
while scouting a potential anomaly in a completely
empty, barren region of deep space.
The Foundation assigns an internal investigator
to the case - one Geoffrey Davies, who schedules
a sit-down with Isaac Miles, the chief technician
in charge of the probe and many others under
Foundation command.
Probe H9’s AI system, known as PH9, was
in communication with Miles throughout its
strange journey, right up until the end.
The logs, requested by Davies, are read out.
At first, it seems like a routine signal.
PH9 calls in to base to inform them it has
detected a signal - but not just any signal,
an emergency SOS signal coming from deep in
an otherwise-empty quadrant of space.
Despite having two sensors, the probe is unable
to find anything in that area with its telescope.
Miles authorizes the probe to change its route
to pass through where the signal is coming
from, and PH9 confirms that it will arrive
at the source of the SOS in 399 hours, or
17 days.
The two men exchange some words.
Miles explains he did not contact his superiors
because protocol means they need visual confirmation
before sending a space shuttle in – and
PH9’s telescope couldn’t find anything.
Even though the signal was confirmed to be
human, Miles didn’t want to break protocol,
and let the probe go in alone.
Investigator Davies begrudgingly agrees that
it was a smart decision, and they move on.
An hour after PH9 entered the quadrant of
space where the signal was coming from, Miles
is still waiting for a report.
Finally, he contacts PH9, which informs him
that it is still unable to get a look at where
the signal is coming from, even though it
is so close it will arrive in 4 hours.
Miles, confused by how this is possible, asks
it for readings on its weight and gravity.
The Investigator asks him why he wanted this
information and Miles explains that the probe
‘passed through some kind of event horizon’.
The probe was continuing to move into the
quadrant, but for some reason looked like
it wasn’t.
This happens when something enters a black
hole, but if it was a black hole PH9 would’ve
been unable to transmit and completely destroyed.
Some kind of anomaly had trapped PH9 inside
its massive well of gravity.
When Miles again radioed into PH9, the probe
had a strange response: that it would pass
by the signal source in 4 hours, the exact
same as last time.
Something was obviously wrong with the probe,
as well over 4 hours had passed and the probe’s
signal meant it should be right next to the
source.
Miles decides the probe is faulty, and assigns
Probe J4 to meet it and take it to a repair
facility.
But when Probe J4 arrives, PH9 can’t see
it.
PH9 can’t even detect it using any other
kind of sensor.
But it does detect the same SOS signal, and
against all logic, it’s still 4 hours away.
PH9 tries to offer its coordinates, but it
can’t - in fact, it says that its current
coordinates are ‘outside of Euclidean space’,
like so many non-Euclidean anomalies the Foundation
deals with.
Miles can’t decide whether PH9 has fallen
into a gravity well or something much, much
worse has happened, and PH9 holds position.
Miles explains that then, he called his superiors
to let them know the deeply strange events
occurring in relation to their probes, but
the closest team was a week away - by the
time they arrived on scene to investigate,
it was all over.
They couldn’t advise on what to do about
the probe - there were far too many unknowns
in relation to space anomalies.
And so Miles simply told PH9 to continue on
its course and report back every hour, because
there was nothing else to do and nothing to
lose.
The last hour of reports are where things
suddenly take a sharp turn.
PH9 calls in to command, saying that it is
suddenly detecting a massive object almost
a million kilometres away from it.
The signal source is still 4 hours away, but
this new object is some sort of planetoid,
1400 kilometres across and incredibly light
for its size.
For comparison, the asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs was 10 kilometers across.
PH9 moves to get a better look, but its analysis
keeps failing - because it’s getting closer.
Not just that, but getting closer impossibly
quickly.
In a minute, it’s suddenly 400,000 kilometres
away.
Thirty seconds later and it’s 250,000km
and showing no signs of slowing down.
Before Miles can explain why this is impossible,
the probe reports it is about to collide with
the planetoid.
The last message it transmits before all communications
cease is a single image from its telescope,
showing whatever was about to crash into the
probe: a massive, blurry white sphere, completely
featureless against the starless backdrop.
The men are confused.
Neither of them know what this image means
- by all evidence, the probe was rocketing
through empty space way too fast for anything
to catch up to it.
And yet, something obviously did - something
was chasing the probe.
They agree it wasn’t a rogue planet, and
Davies dismisses Miles with some words of
advice: to start taking his vacation time
and head on home after a final debriefing.
Turning to his aide, he instructs the agent
to file the interview and completely quarantine
that quadrant of space, making sure nothing
enters or exits.
And, ominously, to ensure that Miles gets
‘processed’.
The Foundation does not leave loose ends untied
after all.
Have you managed to figure out what anomaly
this is a parallel version of?
Something going into a contained endless space,
towards a human signal at the bottom that
seems to never be getting closer, before suddenly
being consumed by a blurry white thing?
That’s right, it’s the infamous and notorious
SCP-087, the Endless Staircase.
Many of us are familiar with this anomaly
- we should be, considering how dangerous
and ominous it is to even seasoned Foundation
veterans.
A metal door in the back of a high school
campus, leading down… and down… and down,
endlessly into an inky black void with a bone
chilling weeping and crying of a baby coming
from the bottom, teasing people to try and
find the source.
At first the Foundation were only interested
in finding out where exactly this crying was
coming from - but soon, they realized, just
like Miles, that something was very, very
wrong.
The first explorer they sent in, an older
man, had gone down only a few flights when
he heard the crying and sobbing of a baby
200m away.
Spooked, he was instructed against his protests
to continue descending the dark, damp staircase.
Almost 30 flights down, he suddenly realized
the next landing wasn’t empty like the others
In front of him was a grotesque parody of
a head - an alabaster white face with no mouth
or nostrils and blank, empty white eyes.
Just floating feet above the ground, staring
at that thing.
Despite his terror, the subject began to approach
- just before it suddenly shot up the stairs,
going right for his face.
By the time he reached the top of the stairs
after a panicked, hysterical run, he collapsed
face down on the concrete.
The Foundation’s following attempts fared
little better.
In one, the D-class had descended almost 100
flights of stairs when he encountered the
face.
Doing nothing, they simply stared at each
other - right up until the face again shot
up toward him.
He turned and ran, screaming all the way up
the stairs.
Unlike the first subject, he didn’t manage
to make it out of SCP-087 before he collapsed.
His heart stopped and the Foundation prepared
to send in a recovery mission - until, suddenly,
his heart restarted, but with an abnormal,
unnatural heartbeat.
The subject’s limp form then calmly walked
up the stairs to the exit, closed the door,
sat down, and fell into a vegetative state,
slipping into a permanent coma.
In the next, everything seemed to be going
well, until the subject encountered a strange
hole in the landing with a light at the bottom.
Shrugging, she continues, all the way to the
500th landing, almost two kilometers below
ground, when she decides to go back up against
orders.
Turning around, she is shocked by the presence
of the face only a few inches behind her head.
It had been following her down those stairs
for who-knows-how-long.
And this time, it’s not staring at her - it’s
staring at the researchers behind the screens
of her camera.
In terror, she runs down the stairs, looking
behind her after several hundred feet - only
to see the face still barely a foot behind
her, staring into the camera with a dead-eyed
glare.
By the time she realizes that the sound of
the crying is getting closer, she has already
stumbled and fallen down into the hard concrete,
knocking herself unconscious.
The last thing the researchers see before
the camera cuts out is the face making piercing
eye contact with them.
And of course, the infamous fourth exploration.
Whatever occurred in this final descent into
SCP-087 was so concerning to the Foundation
that they opted to seal all logs of it and
expunge all the data.
We may never truly know what lies at the bottom
of the staircase or what the face wants from
people who enter its territory, just like
how we may never know what exactly Probe H9
was being signalled by, or what the massive
object moving at the speed of light directly
into the probe was.
And just like how the Foundation cleaned up
all the remains of Exploration IV, the Foundation
also plans to make sure Miles cannot tell
anyone about this strange deep-space anomaly.
Now check out “SCP-1548 - The Star, the
Hateful” for another space based anomaly,
or for more from the depths of SCP-087 watch
“The Secret at the Bottom of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED”